그때 당시에는 부동산을 했기 때문에
답사하면서
봤던 기억이 있습니다 여기서 전에
건물 모습은 지금 요겁니다네
[음악]
사람입니다 제가 오늘은 제가
도산도로에서 가장 좋아하는 건물 중에
하나인 하림타워를 소개해 드리도록
하겠습니다 하림타워는 아마 많은
분들이 보셨을 거예요 가로수길을
지나다니면서 좀 눈에 가장 띄는 그런
건물이고
밤에는
굉장히 좀 화려한 그런 외관을
자랑하는 그런 건물입니다 그래서 되게
많은 분들이 알고 계실 것 같은데
할인 본사에 위치는 신사역 1번
출구에서 나와서
국민연금 바로 옆 건물입니다 위치가
굉장히 좀 좋은 건물이고
굉장히 화려하죠 그래서 약간 이런
s자 느낌이 나게 이렇게 외관이
굉장히 좀 화려하게 되어 있는데
저는이
빌딩이 전 모습을 알고 있거든요 제가
전에도 이제 그때 당시에 부동산을
했기 때문에
답사하면서
봤던 기억이 있습니다 여기서 전에
건물 모습은 지금 요겁니다네
굉장히 노후화된 그런 건물이었고 뭐
한 5층 6층 정도 되는 그런
건물이었습니다 그래서이 건물을
95년도에 샀어요 95년도에 낙찰을
받았습니다
경매로 낙찰을 받았는데 그때 낙찰
받았던 금액을 제가 좀 찾아봤는데
없더라구요
근데 아무래도 그때 당시에는 좀
굉장히 저렴하게 매입하지 않았을까
이렇게 예상은 하는데 그때 당시에
뭔가이 신사역 이쪽 대로변 코너에이
땅을 낙찰받았다라고 하는 거는
정말 뭔가 부동산 투자에
조금 감각이 많이 있으신 것 같습니다
그래서 지금이 건물을 가지고 있다가
2012년도에 신축을 했어요 제가
전에 그 도산대로 건물들 몇 개
소개해 드리면서 그때 당시에
노선상업지는 일정한 조건에만 맞으면
용적률을 800%까지 짓게 해줬거든요
그래서 그때 지은 건물들이 되게
많아요 지금이 할인 본사도 그때 지은
건물 중에 하나입니다 그래서
2012년도에 이제 허가를 받고
2013년도에 처음 착공을 한 다음에
무려 3년이 걸렸습니다 그래서
2019년도에 아름다운
건축물 대상을 또 받았더라구요 그래서
여기 지금 보면은
지하 2층에 지상 16층 건물이고요
그리고 이제 외국 그 되게 유명한
건축가님들이 좀 참여를 했더라고요
그래서 100그룹 더 백그룹이라는
업체에서 설계 때부터 이제 같이 좀
참여를 했고이 설계사님 인터뷰한 걸
좀 보니까 미국에서는
BIM 그 시스템을 활용해서 3d로
설계를 해요 3d로 설계를 하고
미리이 공사하는 업체랑 설계 단계부터
같이 이제 조율을 해서 공사 진행이
또 되게 신속하게 된다 하더라구요
프로젝트 전 과정에서 설계사랑
시공사가 같이 이제 조율하면서
진행하는 시스템이고 반면에 이제 한국
같은 경우에는 일단은 설계사가 먼저
그리고 난 다음에 이제 그 설계
가지고
시공사를 찾아다니거든요
금액이 좀 많이
높아지기도 하고 예상치 못했던 그런
스펙들을 또 높게 잡아서 생각했던
것보다 비용이 또 많이 나오기도
하거든요 그래서 처음에 건축가분이
이제 진행을 할 때 이제 3d로
만들어 놨는데 이거를 다시 2d로
바꾼대요 되게 비효율적인 거죠 그래서
아직까지
한국에는 이런 BIM 시스템에 투자를
많이 안 한다고 뭐 이런 인터뷰
내용이 있습니다 여기서 앞으로 저희도
좀 이런 쪽으로 방향을 가야 되지
않을까네 그리고 이제 제한된 면적
내에서 수직으로 형성된 틈새에
저압지대가 좀 형성하게 돼 있어요
그래서 저압지대에서 사무실에 설치된
이런 개폐식
창을 통해서 자연
환기가 된다고 합니다 그래서 그런
부분도 좀 세밀하게 좀 신경을 썼고
스테인리스 스틸 그 타공판이 있어요
들어가서 보시면은
동글동글 이렇게 해 가지고
타공판이 있는데 거기에 이제 불빛이
들어와요 그 구멍이 수만개가 있다
하더라구요 그래서 밤에 보면 너무
이뻐요 그리고 특히 크리스마스 때
거기 이제 트리를
놔두거든요 항상
그러면
정말 포토스팟으로 너무 좋은
건물입니다 그래서 많은 분들이
지나다니는 너무 이뻐서 그 건물
앞에서 또 사진을 또 많이 찍어요
그래서 저는이 지금 건물이 많은
사람들한테 좀 좋은 영향을 주는 건물
같아요
요게 광장 이게 사무실이고 여기
전시장도 있고
다음에 여기가 16층 회의실 아마이
회의실에서는 한강뷰가 보일 것
같습니다 이제 많은 분들이이 건물을
잘 알다 보니까이 건물 이제 비 많이
오면 어떡하냐 그런 얘기들이 굉장히
좀 많이 나왔는데 그 사실 이제 왜
병만 이렇게 해 놓은 거지 안에는
일반 건물이랑 똑같아요 뭐 전혀 문제
되지 않습니다
어디 고여 있지만 아니면 그래서 이게
지금 대지면적이 190평이고요 그
다음에
연면적이
1753평입니다 아무래도이 돼지치고는
최효율 이용을 지금 하고 있는 거예요
용적률을 거의 800% 가까이 받은
건물이니까 그래서 그 일전에 제가
찍었던 그 배경 빌딩
연면적당 가격으로 치면은 한
5,500만원 정도 돼요 그래서
그래서 대략 계산해 볼게요
5500만원에 1753평
그러면 거의 1000억 정도 됩니다
그냥 그냥 예상치에요 여러분들 그냥
그거 매각된 사례 연면적단 가격
대비해서 그냥 이건 단순 계산입니다
만약에 할인 관계자분들이 보시면 오해
안 하셨으면 좋겠어요 그냥 진짜 단순
계산이에요
네 그래서 좀 하림 그 타워를 좀
봤는데 좀 이런 건축물들이 많이 좀
생겨났으면 좋겠어요 그냥 일반적으로
건폐율 용적률에 마친 그런 일반
컨트롤 c 컨트롤 V 같은 그런
건물보다는 좀 이렇게 신경을 많이 쓴
이런 건물들이 좀 많이
생겨났으면 좋겠습니다 나중 세대를
위해서라도 뭐 이런 건축물들이 좀
많이
생겼으면 좋겠고 해외 외국인들이 또
많이 왔을 때도 이런 건축물로 인해서
또 우리나라에 대한 이미지도 좀 많이
바뀔 것 같고 그래서 저는 개인적으로
좀 이런 건물들이 많이 생겨났으면
좋겠고 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에 또 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다